foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of trash
taste I'm calling and I'm here with the
boys as usual Joey and gone hello yes
I've been wearing this jacket like 10
episodes it's cold it's the winter I
noticed when you find a piece of
clothing you like you'll just wear it
for like an entire year until you get
bored of it I saw a comment on last
week's episode it was like near the top
and it just said like oh thank God
Conor's wearing something other than
merch well I was wearing it underneath I
was wearing it underneath right so
yeah it kind of has like a a winter
outfit yeah a spring outfit a summer
outfit I like I like winter a lot
because you can you can accessorize
right you can you can add jumpers you
can have coats yeah yeah because the
T-shirt game for me is lacking right and
I I just have T-shirts so I think the
T-shirt game just in general is hard to
you know be stylish with right because
it's like normally to look stylish you
got to like layer up but you don't want
to do that especially in Japan because
it's like 45 million degrees humidity
yeah I do not like I've never been able
to figure out my summer fit like ever
there's no such thing I'm still trying
to figure it out because I've tried
wearing shorts and I'm just like I I see
you know some of the models and you know
some of the drip that you can wear in
summer I'm like yeah that doesn't look
bad I try it I'm like I just look like a
clown I don't know why it just no I
don't know I think I think you can make
it work it's it's a matter of confidence
that's that's that's what I see it's I
think I think anyone can make like
summer drip work but I think a lot of
people are just very insecure about it
because they're like oh it doesn't look
good on me because you see all these
models wearing around you're like well
I'm clearly not a model I'm clearly
nothing close to that person so if I
wear what they wear then it's not going
to work out for me but like you can make
it work okay let me let me rephrase I
have in summer I have One Singular good
outfit that I think looks good and I'm
like how many times like can I get away
with wearing this out before I have to
like change into something else so so
what's your outfit
um like just
like like a t-shirt yeah like a t-shirt
and shorts combination with shoes that I
like and then I try to like accessorize
and change that and you don't get a lot
of choice in summer to like swap things
around right because like I don't think
I look good with bright colors on me a
lot of the times maybe it's all it's a
mindset it is
but I will like go for as long as I can
to not wear shorts like it could be
[__] me too a little bit too yeah
like in Thailand it could be like 32
degrees or something and I'm like I can
get away with wearing jeans I think
you're a Madman I can do it you're an
actual mad man at the moment it's like
anywhere above 25c I'm like all right
busting out the shorts that's fair
enough like I just I don't know I hate
having my feet like constricted like
even now I'm wearing like very loose
pants I feel like that's the Aussie in
you though you know yeah that's true
because in Australia we wear shorts like
10 out of the 12 months obviously he's
like can I get away with wearing sandals
and shorts I'm gonna [__] do it
sandals a lot of shoes I like putting
the clothes hug me they hug me like like
a good pair of jeans that constrict your
blood vessels I like that
no I don't like that yeah because
because I noticed out of the three of us
yeah um even if it's like a boiling hot
summer day Sun's beating down on us
Conor will still wear long sleeves no
matter what yeah so
um I'm not in the Sun for long
generally yeah
and I find that having like long sleeves
on means one I don't have to apply
sunscreen all over my arms when I go
outside right but also I'm like less hot
for the first like 20 minutes I'm
outside because the sun's not because
the sun's not touching my skin right
right so after that yeah obviously it's
like I get really hot so yeah I'm never
really outside for more than like 20 30
minutes so I just prefer to wear long
sleeves so the sun doesn't like I guess
burn my arms yeah and that I can just
kind of like I'm I'm initially less hot
I don't know if this is any actually
like I don't know if this is all in my
head well no I think it makes sense
right because like isn't it like you
know people
the sun feels really intense but like
you know when you like go out into the
desert they say it's better to actually
like cover up yeah the skin as possible
because like the Sun hitting your skin
actually does more damage than the sweat
you produce or whatever yes I don't know
how accurate that is but yeah because
okay so I don't know if this is like a
contradictory thing
um because I've noticed
um that you know I'm a summer kid I love
the summer Vibes and I love like going
to the beach and everything like that
um but contradicting contradictory to
that is I hate being in the sun
I don't know also controversial opinion
hate being in the sun yeah I mean you
know I know you love your winter and
everything like that you know I actually
really like the summer but the feeling I
like the most right so every time we go
to the beach and we I have a holiday
with the mates or something it's a beach
holiday I'm that one guy who will do
whatever I can to just find shade and
stay in the shade I really like the
feeling of having a really hot day and
just chilling out in the shade but like
I'm like the one guy on the beach under
an umbrella everyone else is sunbathing
I'm like you guys are [__] madman but
maybe I'm like maybe I'm the madman for
going to the beach and not liking not
wanting to be in the Sun but just liking
the feeling of like being in this I feel
that doesn't really apply to countries
that have like really bad humidity like
Japan for instance because a lot of days
you could be in the shade during the
summer here in Japan and it feels no
different to being in the sun that's
true like the humidity definitely like
is effective yeah the humidity is like
to kill it like it makes sense like say
like back home in Australia where it's
like a very very dry summer right where
like the moment you walk out into the
sun you could probably fry a [__] egg
on your forehead but the moment you go
into the shade it's like oh it feels
like I'm in front of an AC like it makes
sense for countries like that but in
Japan I've like I walk outside I'm like
okay I'm sweating my tits off you go
into the shade still sweating my tits I
just feel it doesn't work
um I mean it I mean it can work uh not
in the city uh I feel like I always like
the nice Sea Breeze or just anywhere
with like a nice breeze and just
chilling out in the shade honestly one
of my favorite core childhood memories
is just sitting on a like lying down on
a hammock I think hammocks are the one
of the most underrated things of all
time I agree does anyone not rate them
highly I feel like everyone writes them
highly who doesn't like everyone One
race them highly but very few people
actually own one
that's the thing and I'm saying it is
worth the commitment if you if you don't
have someone to tied up to you gotta you
gotta figure out to get this big ass
metal thing and it's massive and it's
right you know it's not easy to move
around you know like ah I I think the
one thing I like about the summer is
like the evenings when you know the
sun's gone down and it's like still warm
but it's not like excruciating because
of the Sun so like being outside and
like going for walks like at night and
stuff like that and like feeling the
kind of warm-ish air but it's like it's
still it's still yeah warm air share
like it's still hot but it's not like
the uncomfortable heat that you get
during the day right yeah no that's what
I like about this during the day it can
[__] off yeah I totally agree like in
the summer at about like midday 12
o'clock I just I just stay inside but
like to contrast that my favorite my
favorite like kind of feeling and Vibes
out of like any time in the year is a
summer evening around 5 p.m the sun's
not gone down but the sun is almost like
setting and it's just it's that that's
like kind of the vibe that I look
forward to every summer sure you know
and you just go out and it's not too hot
but you can still like chill out uh you
can drink outside at a nice bar or
something and just watch the sun go down
Good Vibes man Good Vibes good [__]
Vibes but uh what are you guys up to
well it's been two days uh since we last
recorded and uh so metal yeah yeah so in
those within those last few days uh
Sydney's family have come to visit and
it's their first time in Japan it is
their first they're very American right
in Japan and it has been an eye-opening
experience to say the least okay because
I didn't know if I'd had enough to talk
about within just because I've they've
only really been here for one day right
so I spent yesterday taking care of them
yeah
um and it was certainly eye-opening to
see their perspective on okay
where are the cheese Cuts yeah so to
give a bit of perspective you know
Sydney's family is uh very like when you
think of a Midwestern American family
they are the most typical Midwestern
American Family you can think of I think
the only time uh the only time they've
been outside of let's say they've been
to Asia was to visit Thailand
um and that was because they wanted to
visit my family and stuff like that and
I don't think they've ever been even
like closely close to like acclimated or
even introduced to Asian culture or just
like the Asian mindset before Thailand
um so seeing them here in Japan which is
probably like Asia hard mode you know
what I mean it's it's no it's well it's
unlike a lot of other Asian countries in
a lot of ways yeah yeah exactly even for
Asian countries
um you know Thailand is a bit more I
would say
friendly or like used to having like
foreigners come in and tourists comes in
as well
um it is Japan is even more on the side
of okay we operate our own way and uh
people are just gonna have to get used
to that you know that's totally fine
um but you can have a much bigger
culture shock than you can in other
Asian countries
so yeah so
it's it's uh it was eye-opening for me
because I think in our generation we
have been like introduced to a lot of
different like
a lot of different cultures in the world
you know just by being on the internet
you know yeah and just by
just by being on the internet we see how
different cultures operate and stuff
like that obviously for people in the
older generation that have never really
gone out of like European or American
culture it's something yeah yeah your
parents right
um it's it was it was certainly weird
seeing them seeing how they like
so the first thing that really blew
their minds and I had to like explain
this to them like over and over again
you do not tip here
there's certainly multiple other like
explanations it's probably just so
ingrained into their system right where
it's just like they just accidentally
leave some cash on the table Yeah
because every time you every time they'd
uh encounter someone in the service
industry here they'd ask why are they
doing this not for tips
Bob not for Tears [__] yeah
first encounter they had was going to
the hotel and having a guy
um bring their bags up and and
um I had told them before uh I've seen
it on before that you don't need to tip
anyone here and uh they had assumed okay
that means they don't have to tip the
waiters here but you know they
that could mean you have to tip you know
your handlers here they're you know taxi
drivers that's a whole different deal
yeah yeah
um so it's just their first culture
shock was just coming to like a service
industry hotel and just realizing that
people will just do things for them in
service of them to make them comfortable
uh without any incentive to like have to
tip or anything like that God forbid um
and I was like I was explaining to them
especially in bars and stuff because I
think bars was this was uh bars was
something we'll get to like bars in a
second but bars are something that's uh
in America you know I think
people like people in bars try to
cultivate a nice welcoming kind of
atmosphere so that they can get like
good tips and stuff yeah tipping I think
in like even above like restaurants
tipping in bars I think is a massive
thing because I think that's where the
biggest variance is
um and they were very surprised at just
how many small independent bars there
are in such like a densely compacted
area right and I'm like and they were
like how do they stay in business if not
for tips I like they they it like didn't
make sense for them that's the question
of the centuries I mean I I I've lived
here for like ages and I'm like I'm
still impressed we still don't know I'm
still impressed and I was saying instead
of working instead of working for tips
uh in a lot of places in this a lot of
these independent places in Japan
um I think it's more of like they try to
cultivate like uh uh what's what's like
a loyalty like a loyalty system right
like a patron system where you have
certain regular customers that come back
as often as possible I mean you can buy
a lot of balls and like smaller
independent ones uh you can buy a bottle
and they put your name on it so whenever
you come back in you can drink from that
bottle yeah because it'll pour you you
know and you'll see it because they'll
have like rows and rows of bottles
numbered or have name tags on them
um so that's that's like another way
that they try to make sure that you know
you come back a lot yeah yeah
um and so the first the first restaurant
I took them to yesterday was uh was a
sushi restaurant okay uh because I was
thinking Sushi's like entry level in my
mind well that's like the Japanese food
it's it's real thing about it yeah it's
the Japanese food and it's readily
available in America
um but you know even if it's readily
available in America take a Midwest you
know introduce a Midwestern family to
Sushi they don't eat sushi very very
often
um and uh cream cheese yeah yeah avocado
I mean it's full of California roll
where is it it made me realize that I'd
take it for granted just how like
acclimated a lot of our friends are uh
because the first challenge that uh we
came across was a chops yes Chopsticks
and I'd forgotten that Chopsticks were
just a thing that it's a skill that's
acquired it's a skill that's Acquired
and okay it it did make me think a bit
okay it did it it did make me think a
bit after after seeing them have to like
try to navigate their way around
Chopsticks which in the end I was like
just use your hands because you know
yeah you can you can use your hands with
sushi here okay
all right I guess I'll eat the rice and
the beef with my hands all right because
one of Sydney's aunts did ask for a fork
I think and I was just like just use
your hands okay
we are already standing out
I told my parents I was like hey uh
please practice Chopsticks a little bit
yeah
just use them a little bit yeah oh
because okay it did make me think okay
because I've grown up with chopsticks
okay Asian household I've grown upper
Tropics it's a part of Asian culture in
a lot of Asian countries yeah
is it the best tool in the modern day is
a is it Superior to forks and spoons and
knives the more I use it the more I
think there are circumstances where it's
good and there are other times I'm like
dude just the knife and fork is just the
go yeah yes the you know the Sprint's
never going to be replaced the spoon is
no literally there's no no competitor
yeah that's what they said they set the
hand yeah the spork is the superior
option
the spork okay here's the thing the
spork on paper is the superior is the
superior option to everything but can
you use it without feeling like a
five-year-old no
it does because it's always plastic as
well yes you always kind of feel like
yeah where are the metal forms
yeah yeah because because I was thinking
you know yeah I'm I'm Asian and I I
always like promote you know people
trying to use chopsticks and trying to
like learn different cultures and
everything like that sure but I'm like
you know
never needed a tutorial to you like use
a fork you know and there was there was
no there was never like a learning Arc
in my life to learn how to use a fork
but do you remember like the first time
you learned how to use a chopstick no I
was just I was kind of born with one of
my head honestly like like when I by the
time I like you know gained
Consciousness I was just like yeah
sticks until I was like 15 or 16. yeah
right and I remember having a hard time
like I remember it was tough and like I
remember I would get like hand pains and
wrist pains yeah because it was cramp
right I was holding it so hard yeah so
like tense yeah and it would cramp and I
I just remember it is tough like it does
take a little while I used to it's not
like plug and play Like a Knife before
no it's not I used to use like the the
in Japan they sell like the the Hashi
for children yeah where like the ends
are connected and it's like kind of on
an axis yeah you should use actually I
think was it we use that for Rocky's mom
I saw some YouTuber that would they went
around Japan and they would always bring
it with them yeah oh yeah so they were
ready to go I mean it helps honestly
yeah because like I I remember because
like I remember
learning how to use chopsticks and I
think to this day there is like a proper
like Chopstick technique right it's kind
of kind of like hold it like a pen and
you use one of your things to like yeah
adjust it you know I don't use that
technique I kind of like brute force my
way to just like figure out a way to
like open and close the chopsticks like
it's it's kind of like an extent can we
actually we have some Chopsticks let's
let's let's rate our Chopstick
techniques yeah and because because it
did make me realize huh you know what
because why do we have to go through a
learning Arc just to use one a basic
tool to eat or you just you figured it
out I figured out myself me too and I
think yeah I've somehow figured out the
way where everyone else does it right
I'm like you know you know I'm like you
know maybe the Europeans were kind of
onto something because they they just
they just figured out a plug and play
kind of system
like I I guess with sushi a knife and
fork is not as good as a drink no no the
chops is tough because you're supposed
to own Sushi if I'm not mistaken okay so
Joey you have you have the proper
technique right show us the proper
technique to use the Chopsticks so the
proper technique okay so I kind of have
to show like this yeah yeah I do it
right yeah um but for me this bottom
Hashi stays like like stay still that's
probably just move the top one yeah but
I have seen people like my granddad for
example my channel yeah I'm not Chinese
my Japanese Granddad and my sister they
do like a cross technique they do this
oh I've seen that and I'm like how
though and then and then and then they
pull it up and they do this and I don't
know how to do that but my granddad did
it my mum does it my sister does it and
I I do it this way which is I think
that's the correct word how do I do it
this is oh this is hard Chopsticks yeah
so when I eat I do like that yeah so
that's correct I don't know okay that's
just like the way I think that's correct
okay so that's that's the correct way
and that's like I I only use that if I I
only use this way because if I need like
Precision because with this one you can
really get precise yeah because some
restaurants right like yeah it's rude to
leave any rice Left Behind yeah unagi
right if you get nunagi and you leave
the rice it's like yeah well it wasn't
good enough but yeah you have to eat
literally every single grain of rice and
you [__] need that yeah because
you've got to go around the box like
picking every grain up yeah so this is
the correct technique to use as
Chopsticks I think is it not are you
holding it weird like how are you
holding it oh because I I was going to
say I was going to say I have my own
method of using Chopsticks
I guess I guess I just developed as a
kid yeah because [__] is that right yeah
yes
this is just my own technique which is
which is I don't know there's there's no
way you could pick up something okay so
you pick up something you just like
bring it in and you use one of your
fingers to like part the Chopsticks like
that okay and this is the worst whatever
it is it is the worst way but it was
like the only way that I could like
try try to pick up the chip yeah okay
this bag because like it was it was the
only way like I could like do it it's
just that's impressive that they've
worked like my God does that look
inefficient it looks like probably if no
actually this uh this the reason I use
this technique is because like my
parents were just like that's not a
proper Chopstick technique use the
proper Chopsticks and they like like
like this the Precision technique and I
that this would just give me hand cramps
I was like Mom this just ain't doing it
for me okay so I'm just like I just I
just tried to like find a way I just
tried to find a way to like make my
hands not cramp and this way was just if
it's like it's more comfortable on my
hands and I could I can pick up like I
can pick up stuff I can do normal things
but it's not very good with precision
and it's awful with Korean style
Chopsticks as well I hate Curry I hate
metal chops yeah metal Chopsticks I hate
it yeah when you bite because like you
know sometimes you have some foods you
try to put it in your mouth from the
Chopsticks and you sometimes you
actually touch the Chopsticks right yeah
yeah I was like a barbarian but again
metal you're like oh question how do you
hold a pencil then I don't know because
the way I hold the Chopstick is the way
I hold a pencil uh
yeah I like that yeah like this right
okay I hold it like this I guess I guess
how the [__] are you doing I don't know
this one this has always just felt
uncomfortable for me I I guess I I you
know what I just realized I guess I hold
the pencil the same way I hold a
chopstick yeah but that's that's all it
is right you just you get the you just
pretend the pencil is the top Chopstick
and then you just slip the bottom one
underneath and you hold on to it you
guys don't want to know how god holds
his dick when he pisses us
a picture of like yeah
yeah exactly how I do it yeah yeah yeah
like that yeah so I have my own like
home brew method of like holding a
chopstick and using a chopstick and it
works it works my entire life if it
works it's just like some foods even in
Japan where I'm like man this is just so
much harder with the chop like
Chopsticks right like let's say you want
to uh
um
so even even like sushi sometimes
Sushi's supposed to dip the meat in the
soy sauce yeah so that means you have to
grab it and then kind of turn it yeah
yeah which is kind of a hard time even I
struggle to do that because sometimes
the sushi will fall the um the rice will
separate from the fish when you turn it
upside down I'm like dude okay one hands
Superior for the sushi I mean with sushi
I just I just use my hands yeah that's
fine but like um sometimes if you're
having uh something that you need to dip
into like three things yeah let's say
you're having like a beef bowl or like a
sugar Yaki or something yeah where
you're getting rice and then you're
grabbing a piece of meat and then you
want to dip it in mayo or some sauce
okay I am like getting four layers of
things now and I'm hoping it stays
together yeah whereas a fork you can
just scoop stab and then dip yeah like I
can use chopsticks to eat rice but I'm
like
is is Chopsticks Superior to a spoon
like Superior to a spoon in in terms
like eating rice in terms of just like
ease of ease of use and uh functionality
you know because the thing is Chopsticks
look cool I'm I'm not gonna lie
Chopsticks just look cool and they feel
cool I can say this because I'm I'm
Asians
I'm bringing this up because I because I
like if Conor brought this up they would
be like like eyebrows like raising but
I'm like you know there's a kind of
Elegance to it yeah like it does feel a
bit more elegant I don't know why maybe
because it's like very precise yeah um
but there are some foods they've given
me Chopsticks in Japan where I'm like no
this is not allowed uh I went to an
Italian restaurant one time and they
serve me pasta with chopsticks oh that
yeah and I was like the [__] is this I
also refused yeah Italians are crying
yeah I also refused to eat salad with
chopsticks as well yeah maybe he loves
eating salad like some
yeah yeah I want to just stab all the
leaves and get them all I don't really
pick up each individual like leaf with
chopsticks yeah okay real sidetracked
anyway sorry yeah I I just realized that
uh you know trash day try not to have a
tangent challenge
fail because I just realized that spoons
and Fork don't really have a skill
ceiling and Chopsticks do and I'm like
an entry a barrier of Entry barrier of
entry and a skill ceiling as well
because you want to see my trick shots
with a spoon this episode is sponsored
by raycon all right boys let's be honest
and have any of you actually stuck to
you when you use resolutions no no
here's a piece of advice guys even the
smallest thing can make a big change in
your life if you commit to it daily and
use it every day like my Recons raycon
is premium audio at the perfect price
point so you can build great habits
without breaking the bank whether you're
looking for a pair of everyday earbuds
low latency gaming headphones or a
speaker with a battery that will last
all night at your next party raycon's
got you covered and yep raycon starts at
half the price of other premium audio
brands raycon has three customizable
sound profiles earbud tap functions
noise isolation awareness mode the list
goes on I personally love using raycons
on the go which is why its awareness
mode is so useful for me it lets me hear
surrounding sounds when I'm out and
about and I need to be aware and this
water and sweat resistant as well so
it's perfect whenever I'm working out so
ready to buy something small with a big
impact go to buy recon.com trash taste
today to get 15 off your raycon order
that's by raycon.com trash taste to
score 15 off by raycon.com trash taste
this episode
sponsored by Honey the easy way to save
when shopping on your iPhone or Computer
Boys how do you feel when you find a
deal pretty exciting pretty good Connor
yeah what about when you're surprised by
a deal oh this is even more exciting I
wish that would happen to me well wish
no longer gone because thanks to Honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past really but yeah yes
but how does it work I'll tell you God
imagine you're shopping on one of your
favorite sites imagine it right now
everyone watching this imagine it right
now when you check out the honey button
appears and all you have to do is Click
apply coupons wait a few seconds as
honey searches for coupons you can find
for that size and if honey finds a
working coupon you'll watch the prices
gentlemen I've been trying to get a
little bit more fit recently I recently
bought a Fitbit and honey saved me
fifteen dollars honey doesn't just work
on desktops it works on your iPhone too
just activated on Safari on your phone
and save on the go and if you don't
already have honey you could be straight
up missing out straight up and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting this show yes get
PayPal honey for
[Music]
um but yeah just having to teach them
how to eat a sushi as well because uh
the the first thing with your mouth the
first thing okay is is this like I I
thought it would be obvious right you
have like one piece of sushi a piece of
sushi is like a bite yes and I saw like
the first thing uh some of her family
members did uh was like bite half of it
I they're pretty just precarious they're
pretty scared of it yeah they're
probably like oh it's a piece of raw
meat uh maybe it's a type of fish I've
never had so let me just take a test
bite I don't want to eat the whole thing
in case it [__] sucks yeah you know I
got it yeah I mean uh maybe they have
small mouths I don't know
no because it was it was uh it was it
was interesting just to see how the
their approach to like even like the
smallest things
um and just seeing all of the different
types of fish as well because you go to
sushi and they were used they they had
sushi before but it was basically only
tuna and salmon yeah well thank God they
have those yeah yeah salmon is like the
Gateway it's like just like try the
salmon first this is really different
yeah but if you if you're stuck on the
tuna and salmon you you just might as
well not go into that rabbit hole you
know exactly exactly and then just uh
seeing them have uh the salmon Row for
the first time and you made them eat
salmon Roe the first time yeah I mean I
I got I got the sushi platter
[Music]
I bet they didn't like that
mixed mix and mixed opinions mixed
opinions but it's weird because like you
see salmon row and like some some
westerners are like no fish eggs no but
then you see caviar as like this you
know sought after kind of like very
expensive fish eggs as well is it a
mental thing I think I think it's the
size of them and I I don't know for me
the first time I remember it was how red
they were it's kind of weird like for
some reason the because caviar is black
I never thought about it much I never
put much I think it's also because like
salmon or is also like slightly yeah
like translucent as well so you can see
the inside like red part too so it
really looks like some frog eggs or you
know like some like some eggs like
actually unusual to have spherical stuff
like that
think about the thing about Western food
okay what is the the closest comparison
to Salmon Roe that like we that we often
eat like there is no like we don't have
other than regular eggs yeah yeah right
yeah like like my point is if you if you
gave someone caviar in uh the UK but you
spread it on a piece of toast they'd be
like what the [__] yeah
like because they're like this is a like
I don't associate this this shape and
this a quantity is food I know it sounds
weird but I think that's genuinely like
a part of it yeah it could be I'm
thinking I'm thinking about it I'm like
spherical things are the closest thing I
could think of was like Tapioca And that
didn't get like like that's not really
that popular that's all though yeah that
didn't get popular until like the past
few years like bubble tea and stuff like
that I do think uh uh when you're being
trying to get people to try new foods
and being open with it yeah having the
food resemble other foods that they eat
is a lot yeah like the fish right I
think the biggest obstacle is that this
looks like nothing that I.E yeah yeah
right if you gave me a meat substitute
like any kind of wild animal people
don't bat an eye because they're like it
kind of looks like it just looks like a
beef chicken so you're like oh I know
what this is going to taste like then
you try it and you're like oh that's a
bit it's a bit weird it's a bit
different I think I think it's the fact
that it looks different you can clearly
see the textures different you're kind
of expecting the worst right yeah right
I mean okay I have a confession the
first time I came to Japan I had the
sushi and I think I just wanted to like
it so badly that I pretended I liked it
more than I actually did because I
really wanted to I Really but I I think
at that point I I I've been super
British my entire life and I'd never had
anything even like I'd barely ever eat
like just salmon yeah like raw it was
always grilled yeah or steamed right
like I never had even raw salmon so even
even the raw sound was like a step for
me where I was like oh yeah um and it
wasn't only until after I lived here and
actually forced myself to kind of you
know eat it a little bit every now and
then and then eventually you get like a
weird craving for it and then you start
then you kind of realize oh I think I
like this a lot now yeah um Sydney often
tells me and I don't know if this is
true at all but Sydney often tells me
that your taste buds change every like
every few years or something like that I
think so
um and I don't know if it's like that
exact time but I did definitely evolved
yeah and I'm like my like I'm like what
are your sources Sydney and she's never
given me my time but like I I can say
from personal experience especially with
sushi um I grew up I grew up thinking
Sushi was like disgusting right like
that was you there was like something
about every time someone was eating
sushi something about the fishy smell of
sushi and like the smell the smell of
like the soy sauce specifically because
uh you know true
true Sushi soy sauce has like that a
little bit like that fishy kind of like
sea smell yeah you just like fish oil
yeah
and that smell always put me off and I
was I remember growing up I was like I
hate sushi don't like it it's gonna make
me throw up and then I remember like
when I was about 23 or something I
remember the exact moment because I was
on a date with Sydney
um and this was like the first few
months that we were dating and she'd
ordered Sushi and I'd never I'd never
even thought Sushi came close to
appetizing in fact it was like sickening
for me she ordered Sushi it was like
basic ass like cheap salmon sushi
somewhere in London not even like
Gourmet Sushi it was just like cheap
salmon sushi and I remember just
it was a Japanese restaurant right
um and I remember the sushi play coming
out and something in my mind just like
clicked and something my mind just went
that don't look so bad actually yeah
that happens a lot I find myself wanting
to try foods that I think I remember I
didn't like yeah again even if I if I
dislike them again but I want to try
yeah yeah yeah absolutely yeah and I
remember I remember I remember telling
Sydney like before before we started
dating I was like yeah I hate sushi just
like don't if we're gonna go on a date
somewhere go somewhere where I can order
something other than Sushi if you're
gonna order sushi I remember she ordered
that plate I looked at it for a second
and I was like can I can I have a bite
can I can I try that yeah and she was
like really surprised and I tried it and
my brain was just like oh you like this
now this is this is this is actually
slapping like you need to get more of
this I went from like hating Sushi to
now Sushi is like one of my favorite
Japanese dishes like I Sushi is the one
dish where I have not I have not got
bored of after moving to Japan yeah yeah
for sure I love fish now a lot yeah all
right like even when I go to like
America or the UK If there's a grilled
fish on the menu I'm like dude yes I'll
take that over a steak another fish I
used to hate mackerel as well [__]
love mackerel's right Knuckles [__]
but I remember he had such a strong
fishy taste when I was a kid and my mom
would cook it every now and again I'd be
like okay this is this is the [__] food
day okay thanks man thanks I have to
cook macro again I don't had it in Japan
I'm like I [__] love my I love macro
now man yeah I when I uh you know when I
was on the chicken and broccoli Diet and
I lost a lot of weight yeah because
chicken broccoli was my like that's my
dinner but for lunch a lot of the time I
used to go to like Aldi and I would just
buy those uh canned mackerel oh yeah it
was like in tomato yeah yeah because
there was like 100 calories and it's
like a ton of protein and I would just
eat canned mackerel like every day
because you could heat it up in a pan as
well yeah it was so good I love mackerel
I've always loved it and sardines too
even though they're a little bony
sardines are okay I like sardines but
man it's like they it's like they've
been designed to spite humans for
farming them because the little
crunchiness and sometimes there's so
many bones yeah yeah yeah for sure yeah
have you ever had your taste buds
changed because oh you seem to be
someone who likes everything Joey truly
I didn't used to like concrete and now
I'm a big fan
I just started chewing on my mattress
one and I was like oh it's actually kind
of good no it's um when I was like uh up
until maybe around like middle school
high school I base I I despite what you
know that scene in old boy where he eats
the octopus yeah I just hit this vision
of Joe watching it being like [__] wish
that was me
and he he's the live octopus
Joey's like damn I do actually like that
yeah wait what live octopus yeah I've
had it before in Japan what yeah what
the [__] yeah have I never told you
when I went to Oklahoma for a sponsored
video this was [__] like five six
years ago what's wrong with you dog we
went to this restaurant
the guy like he pulled out a live box
and they he [__] decapitates and cuts
the legs in like a matter of like 15-20
seconds to the point where yeah the
tentacles are still wriggling around and
they give it to you and they're like eat
it and and you have to chew it like a
lot because if you don't chew it enough
then the suction cups can get stuck in
your throat
bro
and then I'm like this is the freshest
[__] like octopus Sashimi I've had in
my life probably because it was a live
20 seconds no life that's the best spice
you know yeah I love it I love it when I
swallow in the life just dreams out of
whatever I just stayed no but um like
when I was in Middle School High School
like I
basically couldn't eat most vegetables
like legit like growing up the only
vegetables I actually enjoyed eating was
cucumber and lettuce
you mean the closest thing to walk
like 95 or something yeah any vegetable
that had any like vegetable
flavored Sullivan water yeah I couldn't
eat it like I hated carrots onions like
tomatoes like peppers I still think
carrots are like tea or vegetables I'm
like the best but you know I can eat
them now before I used to like I
couldn't even eat them I was like I
[__] hate all of these and then just
one day for some reason I was out with
some friends and uh there was like a
small little like salad I think with
like whatever I was eating and I had
like you know like carrots and you know
everything that was you know with
lettuce and cucumber and I was like
that's how we get them boys yeah and
then and then yeah it was kind of the
same thing with you with the sushi I
just looked and I'm like that kind of
looks good
and I don't know why and I and I ate it
and I was like oh I actually kind of
like this now like salad tastes good
vegetables vegetables taste good and now
like yeah I can pretty much eat all
vegetables now yeah and it's so weird
and and I don't remember what happened
or like what conditioned me to like
suddenly be like that but just one day
yeah like it just clicked in my head I'm
like you can eat this now it's like okay
you're free yeah you're free you can eat
this now you have unlocked a new part of
your brain you've ascended a new level
you may now enjoy vegetables you unlock
the skill tree or vegetables you're good
now I'm interested what Sushi they
didn't didn't like what was it yeah what
was like the okay how far did you go
down I I didn't go that far okay because
I I kind of just uh so you didn't go
down like the sperm sack right I
wouldn't do that I saw I saw the shirako
and I I and I was just like they they
are looking at cuttlefish like it's an
alien thing right now so I'm just like
uh which was something I unfortunate
which one's that one what sound Japanese
cuttlefish is like the small squid
looking yeah it's like the white one
yeah it's the it's like the whole squid
is on top of it oh that's called a fish
squares it's a it's a small yeah it's
like it's like a type of squid
yeah yeah that one even I'm not I think
it's cool yeah even I'm not a big fan of
that one it's not just really chewy yeah
I just get through this one yeah it
tastes like nothing yeah
um I happily introduced them to fatty
tuna though which
oh that's like like if if you want to
introduce your family or someone foreign
to something that you could it's really
hard to get outside of Japan unless you
pay up the ass and then they're like
that all of them they [__] love that
it's got fats man of course man of
course yeah yeah
um because like it's kind of like it's
kind of like just normal tuna but just
like H5 wagy yeah it's like the A5 wagyu
of tune uh of tuna yeah which is good
um but surprisingly they actually
enjoyed most most of it I think the
salmon row was the only thing that they
really were just like it was the day it
would try uni
no okay and that's from that's the one
where I understand that it's love for a
lot of people but I don't like uni
that's yeah that's the Dark Souls boss
of sushi right it's like it's like it's
the mama yeah
I think there's just something in it
that just doesn't drop like what don't
you like about it it's like a gas in my
mouth it's like I have five like it's
like a bomb is going off of it really
it's so intense and strong because it's
like salty no it's not even that it's
like this is this is weird taste to it
that just isn't I don't know it's not
nice I've heard from people I've heard
people who don't like uni say that they
don't like it because it's like they
just took a mouthful of seawater
maybe that it tastes like it tastes like
soapy to me when I eat it it's like very
chemically like I don't know how to
place it I just I've I've because you
always get it in the set yeah and I
always eat it because I don't want to
disrespect the dude yeah and I just kind
of like it's more of a you just fight
through it
right right I do the Matt Stoney
technique I'm like
oh delicious great yeah yeah it's really
weird because I remember when I first
moved to Japan uh first time I tried uni
wasn't a fan either it was something was
off about the taste and then I just had
this one great experience in Hokkaido
and of course yeah yeah that's where the
third eye of food
and then I had this one uni in Hokkaido
and then like a like we just talked
about something something in my brain
just like clicks and switch and it just
unlocked this new skill like uni skill
tree in my brain and then after that one
experience I [__] love uni yeah I
don't know what it is it was just having
that that perfect balance between
something it was like a little bit sweet
but just like the right kind of sweet
but also it's like a creamy salty type
of fish creamy salty and sweet yeah like
one little package so did you did you
take them to like a sushi chain or like
some fancy place oh no honestly because
uh
yeah I'd say Sushi Rose solid bro yeah
I mean we went to uh so first place
Sydney wanted to take them was askusa
you know kind of like you know do the
rounds of nasakusa uh and we just went
to uh it was unsurprisingly very busy so
we went to a sushi restaurant that
seemed to be a local place there uh
didn't have an English menu so that's so
that's that's why I was less full than
some of the other sushi places
um so it was kind of like a lot it
wasn't a chain it was just like a local
locally run sushi place
um and yeah uh they very much enjoyed
the sushi experience which was good got
the good first pass uh took the round
ascusa uh which was
taking people around USA I've never
heard anyone pronounce it that way yeah
that's my shitty pronounce here it's
confusing because there's asaksa and
then there's yeah as well yeah uh yeah
showed them showed them the temple and
everything like that and I think they
got a bit shocked where uh not not
shocked but it's uh they saw like the
trust system in full effect where you
know like when you get like the uh or
the omikuji yeah yeah uh and there's no
one there's no one looking but you have
to like pay 100 100 yen just to get your
fortunes done and stuff like that
there's no one looking at all you could
just you could just get yourself you
could just take one you could just take
one and uh you know no one's looking and
uh and that's when I had to explain to
them about Japan's trust system where
you are Americans just I still waiting
there are some places in Europe in
America that I I have it like in rural
areas oh yeah yeah for sure they have um
like Farms have you know you can just
but you pan is one of the few places I
feel we're going to also do it in urban
areas like more commonly than other
places I feel for sure for sure yeah
yeah
um and so we uh did that experience and
then we got to the evening and then we
were like I was I was trying my best to
figure out a good way to introduce them
to uh Tokyo and Japanese nightlife and
drinking culture here and stuff like
that and I was thinking you know maybe
in maybe in Izakaya would be like good
and stuff like that for sure and Sydney
was like no oh god let's listen let's
not do that uh Cindy's like let's go to
a girl's bar oh my gosh
because because it's
because it's Sydney why does she want to
go to a girl Spa because it's Sydney I
know Sydney Sydney probably walked in
was like don't worry they know me let me
genuinely like enjoys going going to
girls boxes
because she just wants to talk right
yeah she just wants to talk Japanese one
of the first places we go so it's uh me
Sydney her parents and her uncle and
auntie right
she goes up to one of these girls uh who
is promoting promoting like a random
girls bar or something like that and she
goes oh can uh can we have a can we have
a uh do you have space for six
and uh the go goes yeah and then Sydney
calls over her family and just the
realization in the girl's face where she
realizes the customer base that she's
bringing in is so far beyond so far
removed from the customer base she is
used to like a group of American
tourists not even young American
tourists just like a family
probably like you you do realize what
you're about to go into right like this
isn't a diner no we don't do that here
no we don't do that and so um and so we
we go in and it's it's a very small
girls bar so we there's not really like
any tables there sure there's one like
L-shaped counter and that's kind of it
so I'm like okay Sydney you take that
side and I'll take the other side just
so you know just so there's always
someone who can kind of speak Japanese
on either side yeah the girls want to
like get friendly and uh talk to talk to
the family members and stuff like that
and so I sit next I sit next to Sydney's
mum and Sydney sits on the complete
opposite side uh of the bar
uh and so the girls come over and they
start talking and explaining the system
of this bar uh which was uh which my
parents uh sorry which Sydney's parents
and family were just like as what's what
kind of service do they offer here I
don't really understand because uh they
they came over and they were like so
it's uh it's thirty dollars per hour uh
and uh you know you can order all of
these drinks from the menu so in the
typical girls bar you kind of you kind
of pay for the company yes right yeah
the drinks are just kind of included to
keep you paid to talk to girls basically
yeah you basically I was trying to find
the way the best frame of reference to
explain what a girl's bar is
to uh Sydney's family because they were
they were like as Fish Out of Water as
you can get yeah they were probably just
expecting a box it's like it's like it's
like Hooters except you don't pay for
the drink you pay for the time you're at
Hooters yes yeah so the way I explained
it was okay stick with me for a second
um so you know how in America they have
strip clubs right I was like
yeah so so imagine imagine strip clubs
you have strip clubs yeah and I was like
stick with me stick with me for a second
so it's kind of like strip clubs but
instead of paying for girls to strip uh
you pay for girls to converse with you
yeah and so the girls are incentivized
to be very very friendly to the customer
base and Converse with you yeah and um
so I that's what I explained before
going in and uh even explaining that I
don't think my especially my
mother-in-law was prepared for let's say
how uh energetic and in character the
girls were going to be right
your Sid's mum you're you're used to
like very local Friendly Midwestern bars
and stuff like that and you come in and
there's a cute captains Japanese Goku
Going like
was it like uh it was like a themed one
or is it just like a bog standard like
this it was a themed one it was like a
kind of like a uh I think they're only
in like Chinese dresses and stuff like
that I'm not sure what the exact theme
was all right yeah yeah but I've been to
like plenty of girls bars uh because of
Sydney I should say probably like the
only probably the only goal probably
only like girlfriend that actually drags
their partner to girls bars but uh yeah
some girls bars can be like some girls
bars you can tell they're just there for
the costume yeah yeah and some girls
bars you they're there and they're
actually like really enjoying their job
and in character and stuff like that um
this was the latter one so it was like a
very very energetic girls bar
um so the first thing that happens uh
that happens is I sit next uh Cindy
takes one side I take the other one of
the girls comes over and uh she asks
yeah
she asks if
uh she asks if my mother-in-law is my
girlfriend
because that's that's
his mom was flattered by that
just
I'm just like no no no no no this is
this is this is my mom this is my mom
please this is my mom she's like oh
Carson and I was like I had to like I
didn't know the exact word for
mother-in-law yeah yeah yeah
just um yeah sure they kept calling
Sydney's mom Vision
beautiful which is just like the
Japanese word for like beautiful woman
right and uh they um I they I think they
complimented Sydney's mum more than they
complimented Sydney
did Sydney like that or perhaps it was
certainly uh happy about battle uh
Sydney can hear it but I was I was I was
I told I told I was telling Sydney like
halfway through they're like they're
like really like your mom like they
they're sleeping over your mom they're
kind of like all the girls here kind of
like simply
I'm not gonna lie
did Cindy's mom enjoy it oh she enjoyed
the hell yeah I bet honestly
[__] amazing experience like this
Sydney took like a massive 50 50 in like
interesting 90-10 yeah
it was it was very much a 90-10 kind of
experience on whether it's whether they
would have hated it or whether they
would have like really really liked the
experience but one thing I realized is
that if you have the right girls bar
which is a toss-up because it's hard to
find it's hard to find because girls
bars can be completely different Vibes
depending on what kind of bar you go to
yeah
um these girls clearly enjoyed their job
and clearly just wanted to set a good
vibe I felt bad because we walk in and
the only other person in there was this
like old Japanese businessman that's how
they always are that's how they always
are and you can see his face come you
can see his face where a bunch of like
American tourists comes in and uh
because he's obviously like a regular
there
um and now all the girls are going
towards and all the girls are now simply
towards Sydney's mom and he's just like
great but
um oh that's awesome but yeah uh like
they were very like iffy about it going
in uh seeing the kind of vibe and seeing
like oh what kind of what kind of place
has Sydney dragged me into uh but if you
find the right girls bar they are so
good at setting like a good vibe and
something like a certainly Vibe yeah
um that's
you know it's it's just it's just a
really fun time honestly uh and Sydney's
mum had a great time I was telling her
all of the compliments that all the
maids were saying to her uh Sydney like
now is so acclimated to girls bar she
walks in like a [__] mafia boss she
sits down she knows how things work she
knows she knows exactly what to say to
get like the good treatment right right
um and we we come out and actually one
of one of Cindy Uncle one of Sydney's
Uncle who's comes up to me and he goes
you know what probably a good thing I
don't I don't live in Japan because I
would spend way two minutes I would
spend way too much money in bars like
that man and I was like oh oh no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no did you
tell them they could tip sorry they can
kind of chip in those bars you can buy
the gold strings yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
so I told him that uh Sydney did all the
siblings oh she was like whatever you
guys want
city city
I remember I was in one of those bars
all time and um I I was with a friend
there and the girl was very persistent
when I was like what do you I was like
oh yeah get a drink and then she was
like Dom Perignon and I was like no no
what like how much is that she said two
grand I'm like no
sure and then I kept I was like just
pick another drink she's like how about
this other Dom Perrier what
what yeah and so I was explaining to my
uh mother-in-law uh so be careful yeah
so I explained to Sydney's mom and her
aunt that you know there's like the
opposite of girls bars as well there's
like
host bars as well and as soon as I as
soon as I said that after the girls bar
experience they were like tell me more
than that uh the mum and the aunt
tell me more about this there's two
types of guys there's there's hosts and
then there's just guy snack bars yes
where it's basically girls bars they
just talk to you and maybe they
compliment you and stuff yeah the hosts
are more like hosts are like the
one-on-one like here to flirt with you
make you fall in love with me and I'm
gonna like string you on as long as you
keep buying drinks yeah it's like they
like guy snack bars do exist and they're
pretty common as well yeah right I mean
it's the same in with the girls side as
well there's girls bars and then there's
oh that's right I like host clubs or
it's like the girls are there to like
sit with you and to like make you fall
in love with them so you can buy them
drinks yeah yeah because uh because I
honestly think if you want to like learn
to practice your Japanese
um the girls girls bars are like
honestly a great [__] place yeah
right for sure um honestly you can also
go to a place like golden guy as well
where you have normally have very
talkative songs hey you know 50 bucks an
hour for a private lesson when you pay
30 bucks and free alcohol yeah you can
drink all you want it's free alcohol
well it's not free alcohol it's the it's
thirty dollars for all that's a
dangerous mindset hey hey if it's 30
bucks for an hour it's free yeah it's
free I can get through way more alcohol
than that that's what I mean that's true
yeah and you know it's it's it's nothing
most of the time nothing sleazy about it
you're just paying for company and
they're they're just a mindset if you
want him feeling sleazy it's gonna feel
sleepy yeah I'm just gonna hang out
support a local business yeah learn
Japanese not sleazy yeah establish a
platonic relationship yeah because it's
a healthy non-uh parasocial relationship
yeah because you know talking to you
talking to some of the girls there and
uh Sydney talk to a lot of girls who has
worked at different girls bars as well
and a lot of the girls honestly work
there just because it's like a release
for them because a lot of times they
it's they're like really really
extroverted and it's just the perfect
job for them just to be able to like
socialize yeah just let loose in Japan
which can sometimes be really really
hard in a lot of different like jobs and
different social situations as well so a
lot of the times if you find the right
girls uh girls bars they want to talk to
you as much as you know you are looking
for conversation as well they they
genuinely enjoy their job and you're
like there's some there's something just
nice about seeing someone who just
genuinely enjoys what they do yeah and
they're just happy to do what they do
um so that was like day one uh they
packed in pretty early day one that was
day one how long are they here for
they're here for a week so that's gonna
be the most eventful week of their life
not a very long time it's not a very
long time
um but I mean if that was all one day
that was that was then this the week is
gonna be [__] yeah the only reason
the only reason we didn't go on for
longer because I did want to introduce
them to like karaoke and you know or and
you know other just other more
traditional Japanese bars maybe kind of
winning on the team there's nothing more
traditional than a girl's party that's
true that's the most traditional as it
gets honestly how last time went I
wouldn't be surprised if they asked to
go to more girls Spas if I'm being
honest Good Vibes but uh that was day
one we packed it in early because they
were jet lagged and everything like that
so uh but honestly for like the first
day of traveling from America that was I
thought I thought I wouldn't have
anything to say coming in to like this
podcast because I was like I'll talk
about it when the Trip's over and I'm
like [__] it are we there's so much more
stories in a week yeah so much is
happening just one day I'm glad they're
having a good time at least you know I
think honestly Sydney's kind of like a
Banff for just being so fearless and
just being like nope but Mom Dad you're
just gonna come here and uh I'm not
gonna try and ease you into it I'm just
gonna throw you out the deep end because
this is what I want to do
I'll see you I'll see if your parents
I feel they might not have the same
reaction yeah you should be like Mom Dad
have you heard of a girl's Mom let's go
I can't even imagine what they'll be
like I'm having a toilet for me it's
gonna be for once yeah I just I just
remembered as we were like going for a
toilet break there was one other like
Awkward Moment uh go on okay so we we
we're in the girls bar and they had like
a few like magazine promotions for
different Idol groups in Japan and so uh
my mum asks oh what what is that and I
go oh uh that's like they're promoting
like an auto group in Japan it's a
pretty popular culture in Japan and she
asked her what's an idol group and I'm
like oh that's a rabbit hole I'm like
how do I how do I how do I begin to
explain this is this like is this like a
child or like underground Idol group or
like a mainstream Idol group I'll be
honest I have another one I don't know
do you want to explain the difference to
me Joey because I don't I don't know
it's like imagine if BTS wasn't that
popular and they were more about
catering to individual fans it's the
difference between like is it promoting
like you know [__] Imagine Dragons or
some like lesser known like SoundCloud
artist
you know that's that's the difference or
it's like they both have their fan bases
but one is like more you know in the
mainstream and like you know on TV and
[__] and then there are ones where it's
like they play at local venues to like
very small crowds but they still have a
dedicated fan base kind of thing right
because that's the best way to explain
yeah the best uh the way I ended up
explaining it was like okay so it's kind
of like it's it's kind of like a music
group that caters towards a very
specific audience that they try to get
as invested in this group as possible in
order to spend money and that's a very
light it's a very arbitrary way of
saying it though uh yeah because I I was
I was like how do I explain like Idol
culture and then like Midway through
Midway through my shitty explanation
then she goes they look very young
well yeah typically like 19 to 25.
you're correct on that mother yeah
they're gonna be really young yeah she
was like yeah they look very young I was
like yeah and then she was like they
look like very very young and I was just
like I I paused for a second and I was
just like do I want to open this can of
worms pause for a second and I just go
yes
[Music]
you should have said like oh you know
all Japanese women
when someone spends enough times around
they're like what's up with all the kids
stuff
I've had a few friends say that when
they've been here yeah yeah that's true
so what's up with that and I'm like well
that is a uh cultural can of worms that
we can talk about we're going to be here
I don't want to explain yeah for like
six hours yeah yeah yeah but that was
that was like yeah I'm looking forward
to seeing what other parts of Japanese
culture I'm going to have to explain
can't wait for your Sydney's mom to be
like I want to go see these Idol groups
I was having dinner with someone and uh
they they asked me they were like so why
does it seem like nobody's really
friends here and I'm like okay well no
that's uh that's like eight layers of
culture yeah dissect we're like going
back to school we're talking about the
work culture yeah we're going through
everything and it was just like a whole
I realized when I was speaking about it
I was like I should just said something
dumb like I don't really like friends
so like
yeah I kind of realized oh yeah am I
being that guy am I being that guy
that's just like going way too deep into
like a topic over like just a simple
question yeah today at all I don't know
if you had this because I I went to a
restaurant with someone who's visiting
and I was like I told them uh because I
was like I can just order if you want
because I was like I was like they're
gonna freak out if you say something
that they don't understand yeah yeah and
he was like why and I was like I don't
[__] know why because they like they
like the script they like everything
that happens in the way they want it to
happen Okay I don't know why but just
let me order so they don't freak out and
it doesn't get weird and they try to
order they try to take the menu and he's
like no no I want to keep on to it and
they're like what
and I felt I felt bad because I was like
the guy was doing like the like like the
yeah how does this compete looking
around for the manager genuinely yeah he
was like he was like what do I do I was
like I was like it's okay we'll just eat
we'll look at the menu it's fine yeah
this is how games must feel when like
speed Runners stop breaking yeah
what do we do I've clipped into the
restaurant and I've already got the
meals like yeah I wonder if they'll come
across that at all yeah I I I did give
them I did give them a little bit of
advice that uh like backfired a bit
because how do you explain how do you
explain the Japanese accent to someone
who doesn't understand I would say say
it in a very slow way
like you would say yeah like you don't
say cream cheese you say
just say it slower like cream cheese and
they might they'll put it together yeah
sometimes as well the the people who
you're talking to
because you obviously very clearly look
foreign yeah they're expecting you to
say in the foreign way anyway yeah so
sometimes if you say it in the Japanese
way they kind of get confused weirdly I
know it sounds literally me every time
it sounds hard yeah it sounds hard to
believe genuinely like it's like when
you're uh like when you're in like
you're in the UK or something you're in
like a country and then you overhear a
conversation and you're like that
sounded like a different language but it
wasn't right it's weird I don't know how
no I get it like sometimes the
expectation messes with what you're like
actually hearing yeah so I mean I get
that with Korean a lot like uh there's a
there's been so many instances where I
would hear someone in public like what I
think is them speaking Japanese but it's
actually Korean and vice versa yeah yeah
and it's and it's bizarre every single
time it happens the one that's even
weirder is when I think they're speaking
Korean but they're actually speaking in
Japanese no I've heard that as well I've
overheard conversations I think they
think it's speaking a foreign language
for some reason the how my brain heard
those words but no they were speaking
English yeah it's so weird I get that
with Vietnamese a lot like every time I
hear Vietnamese especially Vietnamese
um I I like look up because I'm like oh
someone's speaking Thai and then I've
realized it's a completely different
language right it's like they're saying
words I should understand but it's just
it's something about it just doesn't
comprehend in my mind I think what it is
is like the inflections are similar yeah
but the words exactly like the same with
current like the with Korean is like the
inflection is so close to Japanese but
it's just the words and like some sounds
they make are just like oh that's not
Japanese yeah the [__] is that the [__]
is that yeah I think have you ever seen
that video where it's kind of like it's
like what English sounds like to people
who don't speak English that's exactly
like I love that video that's that video
just like unlocked another part of my
brain to realize oh okay I get it now
yeah I this is this is what people hear
because that's kind of a very similar
feeling to why here when I hear someone
speaking Vietnamese I'm like oh wait
tight no why I understand this what yeah
it's pretty interesting when I go to
Vietnam for the first time actually yeah
yeah yeah because uh you're going you're
going for the first time in Vietnam this
year as well aren't you yes yeah I'm
going to uh Vietnam for my mom's 60th
birthday because uh for some reason I'm
the only one in my family who's never
been to Vietnam my sister has been like
four she's like hiked across Vietnam
what like a number of times during
school and like my parents have been
like four or five times and I'm like I
put the food wait where the [__] was my
invite
yeah so I'm looking for it I'm
definitely two weeks Southeast Asian
food sounds so good oh dude Vietnam's
gonna be lit it's gonna be so good I'm
so excited for it that's not happening
for a while but yeah yeah so I've
learned my lesson next time okay next
time I'll I'll recommend Google
translate oh I did recommend oh okay
okay yeah four like menus and stuff
um I was I was just saying just in case
uh you need to like enunciate something
I'm like how can I how can how can I
explain Katakana the Katakana kind of
like English you know yeah now because
like now I realize if I want to explain
to someone if they're into weeb cultures
just say it just be like say it in what
you think is like anime we just turn for
we just turn forward and don't afraid to
turn because I've seen people the real
the reason I realize I went down this
route because because I've seen people
go down the route of just saying the
words slower but just completely like
keeping the English accents yeah like
like when I've seen some people like try
to order like Coke or something
Coca-Cola and they say Coke Coca-Cola
and then they then they try to say
slowly and it's still like Coca-Cola and
you know that doesn't register yeah
quarter you know which is like yeah a
more Japanese like Katakana kind of
accent people get that and the best way
I can kind of like describe that is that
it just sounds what you think we sound
like you know I don't know how else to
explain it I had that I had that happen
to a uni friend of mine who I brought to
Japan for the first time yeah we were at
a Starbucks and he wanted to get a milk
tea and uh and he was at the front and
he was like oh can I get one milk tea
please you know super Australian yeah
and the one was just like uh what the
[__] did you just say yeah and then he
turned to me and he's like how do you
say milk tea in Japanese and I'm like
here's the thing right so he turned
around like it's just like
here's what I've learned from from
learning a language right if you don't
speak the language do not say other
words other than the thing you are
trying to convey yes like if you want a
milk tea at a Starbucks don't say can I
have a milk tea just say milk tea yeah
because then what you're trying to
you're you're putting emphasis on the
communication of just this one thing
you're not because it's going to scare
them if you say all this other [__]
they're like oh what about Emoji like
does you want me to throw it away like
yeah you know what I mean like obviously
it's not that but like you're adding in
confusion well they might not even hear
the word yeah yeah so it's like just say
the thing you want I know it's gonna
make you feel like an idiot but you are
you don't speak the language you're
basically a toddler speak like what you
would put into a Google search bar
basically yeah yeah it's like just the
keywords only that's all you need yeah
but yeah I mean Japan is getting a lot
more Katakana in its vocab in everyday
use but it's it's such a gamble you
never know which words they're using
yeah yeah like certain words you're like
why okay they chose this word all right
cool like uh like they use the word
um
sometimes they use the word assist
sometimes yeah sometimes it's like
the [__] assist like why was that the
word you chose to bring over I think
that's probably because of sports maybe
yeah and like task task they just task a
lot yeah yeah they use
it's just multitask yeah
it's weird the words they choose to
bring over and the words that they they
often uh try and integrate into the
language yeah it's not just English
words either that they do that for so
yeah true you know they use like
arubaito which is the German one yeah
yeah that's a that's an odd choice or
like uh [__] punk all right for bread
oh yeah as well for like uh bell peppers
like those are all European words I
didn't know that yeah yeah and then
luckily in Starbucks you could say soy
milk yes
it's just so annoying to say yeah this
isn't a necessarily long word for you
Junior the soy milk it's just no Union's
just milk oh sorry sorry it's a Tanya
you can just say
yeah
that's like that's like uh like fromage
for us in English it's like it's like
the fancy version of cheese
in France and they're like
oh get a load of this guy getting the
soy milk lattice dude
sometimes you do go to like the French
places and you should actually see like
yes you get [__] though because you're
like you're reading the Katakana of a
French restaurant and it's Katakana for
French yeah you're like [__] I didn't
know this yeah French
that [__] me up so many times but like
if it was in England if it was like in
the the Roman alphabet French I can
normally kind of figure out a little bit
what they're talking about because I'm
like I know these letters to make so I
can kind of put it together but if you
see like
you're just like what the [__] is that
yeah
but I had a friend who uh uh white guy
married to an Asian woman and when he
went to I think it was like France or
Germany he said like oh yeah it is a
little bit of an advantage knowing
English because you can kind of figure
out roughly kind of what the stuff is
from the words right because you can
read it yeah you can maybe you don't
maybe not German but like French you can
kind of figure out roughly what they're
maybe saying yeah you're like yeah it's
a it's an omelette I think
yeah yeah it's Advantage and whereas you
know if you're used to eating Chinese
characters or Japanese it's a lot harder
to be like wow okay what the [__] am I
reading yeah exactly you don't even have
like anything close to a frame of
reference to like build off of you know
and then on top of that we're like at
least Japan is great with signs they put
signs everywhere and symbols they love
putting symbols everywhere in in the UK
holy [__] we don't got [__] you got
nothing in the countryside good luck
that's true actually yeah I didn't
realize that until you said that like
you don't realize how like almost far in
a friendly Tokyo is at times with how
how good it is for helping you get
around yeah uh and and how how they
prefer to use like one pictures outside
and and plastic models and stuff like
yeah dude it's so nerve-wracking going
into like a restaurant in the UK or in
France because you're like bro I don't
know what the menu is I have no idea I
can't read any of them because a lot
more often they don't even show you the
menu yeah so you're just like I don't
[__] know if it's good I'll find it
when I get in and then there's no
pictures yeah not that I needed pictures
I'm not a toddler I know what the stuff
is but it would be nice to kind of see
the portions and the size yeah like a
frame of reference yeah what we're
working with here I want to see
sometimes people make like certain
dishes and they look like ass and then
other places the picture looks amazing
it looks good I want that thing for sure
for sure
yeah but uh that's that's been pretty
much everything I've been up to in the
last few days nice what have you been up
to
um I got a new pc nice yeah because your
basic is breaking for some reason so I
okay this is my I gotta I I don't
reached out to uh sponsor PC specialist
we work with a lot I was kind of like
hey my stream keeps crashing uh it I
think it's because I had like a graphics
card that was bad because I I had an old
PC and I got a new pc because I want to
build a new one because it kept crashing
right and I thought okay well I'm gonna
change everything except the graphics
card and I got the new pc and I built it
and I had problems starting that one
right it went all wrong I had the wrong
I had the wrong Ram it was man it was a
whole thing I got it working I have the
same issue it would just crash and it
would like all what would happen is it's
like blue screen or what no no I I would
um wouldn't even do that
I'll be streaming
all the screens go black the [__] all
right and then it will come back the
string will be ended because the stream
is rendered through the graphics card
yeah yeah it'll stop streaming stop
every application and it'll also act up
weird if I try to restart the stream
it'll kind of struggle with games so I
kind of just have to restart my PC right
and we just keep doing this whenever I
played a game that was pretty intense
and I was like [__] this man I I it
happened once or twice I was like that's
it I'm done I'm like I'm just gonna get
one that is completely brand new has
nothing to do with me I'm not touching
it I don't have anything because clearly
I'm a [__] curse so I got a new pc
and I started setting it up you know how
it is it's kind of exciting when you get
a new pc and you say like I am going to
make sure the file management is clean
as [__] this time and in a month it's
not going to be clear yeah yes but
you're like you're in your head you're
like committed to it and it's kind of
exciting because you kind of get
everything fresh everything's super fast
it all works yeah for sure set it all up
everything was fine
three days later I I shut down the PC
and it had an update but I was like I'm
pretty sure I did the updates so I just
shut it down I went to bed I came back
in the morning and it was on the boot
screen and I was like what the [__] I
shut it down okay and it was just stuck
on it just wouldn't move oh no and I was
like what I'm like oh man oh man so I
try everything that I know yeah I try to
fix it in every single way and I'm just
having no luck and but I know because
it's it's booting and I can get to all
the windows repair stuff I'm like okay
maybe worst case scenario I think I just
have to reinstall Windows but I don't
want to do that because I've already set
everything up and I'm just like oh man
so I contact them I'm like hey guys the
PC is great it's fine it's awesome
beautiful Camp management it's beautiful
490 is so good yeah 40 90. beautiful
that's absolute monster it'll run TFT
amazing
um and um
that's why I asked I'm like hey it's
it's not working it's really expensive
and dude can you help me figure it out
and stuff and so like I got on call with
a a very nice British man uh and he
would walk me through all the stuff and
he was like yep it looks I got to
reinstall Windows I was like
and he was like yeah but he's like so
it's fine that's good that's the best
thing I'm like why is it the best he's
like well because if it was a
replacement if there was anything else
it means it's all [__] yeah it's like
okay
so I had to reinstall windows again do
that so for the last like three days
I've just been reinstalling everything
again and yeah dude it's so finicky
because like man if it was just
reinstalling software it wouldn't be a
bad idea but it's like I gotta reset up
all my stream stuff and it's like so
long yeah yeah for sure and there's
always something you're missing yep and
there's always like and then you're like
doing something and you're like [__] I
didn't install that I gotta do that
again and it just takes like hours like
I don't want to spend six hours doing
this especially not when I've already
done it it's a it's funny you say that
you have like a PC curse because the PC
you built for me like three four years
ago I haven't had a single problem with
yeah
you know you know Joey what if what have
you been using that PC for though you
know I feel like I am I am I am burning
myself I regularly like push my PC like
fully but I still think it's breaking
way more than even should if I'm doing
it yeah yeah yeah yeah like if you were
playing like a triple A game A Lot your
graphics card is probably being fully
used oh yeah for sure so I I don't
understand I shouldn't be doing this
that's why I'm a console game yeah
a lot of the time I'm streaming and so
you're streaming and then you're running
the game and the stream is running off
the graphics card but then I also like
to record locally yes uh just because
stream when you when you upload a stream
to Twitch yeah uh they absolutely murder
the quality yeah like it's even worse
than YouTube like it's so bad yeah
because you can only do six megabytes
per second which is like it looks fine
in 1080P people you can't upload
anything higher like at all and
um it'd be nice because I'd like to
um but it just means that certain games
look like ass like I don't know if
you've ever watched a stream of like
vampire survivors oh yeah yeah where it
just goes like it's just like pixels
yeah you're like oh there are four
pixels on the screen this is like
because the twitch compression just like
it just cannot handle certain things on
yeah there's a lot of stuff on screen I
can't do it I I always locally save my
streams as well so yes I locally save it
because if I want to make a YouTube
video out of it which I do there's like
a ton of benefits one being it looks way
better and you can record a much higher
bit rate yeah uh you can also record a
different resolution which I'm going to
do now I can record it in 2K instead of
1080p so I can the videos will just look
better yeah the reason why you like I
can't attended to be fine yeah but it's
like future proofing like it used to be
that like 1080p was always fine but now
if you play a 1080p video on a TV it
looks like a ass yeah so it's like okay
because everyone has a 4K TV that's like
60 inches right so I'm just kind of
future proofing it yeah also I like to
separate all the audio channels this is
so nerdy I know I'm sorry but like just
so that if Mudah wants to in post he can
edit all the audio levels like if the
game's too loud yeah yeah yeah it's just
like a whole thing
1080p to 4K
kind of kind of get it kind of don't on
a TV you notice the difference because
because maybe nobody notice it on your
phone with a movie you won't notice
right because DVDs they're like expertly
like uh made and you don't get this dog
[__] compression that YouTube does yeah
like our videos in 4k don't look like 4K
because YouTube compresses the [__] out
of them yeah yeah but there's always
going to be compression online yeah I
know I know I know but like if you
watched a movie on a stream yeah it's so
like what are you trying to do is like
if you upload like a higher quality
video to YouTube it'll compress it like
like a stop down right so what you're
trying to do is is by doing a higher
quality is like you're trying to get
ahead of like the YouTube compression so
the 1080p doesn't look like 720 so that
like you know so that when you upload
something in 2K it'll look much better
in 1080P when someone watches it right
yeah I guess because like for me I've
tested around with this before and I've
noticed even if I have a 1080p video
because most anime are in 1080P that's
why yeah
um that's fine for you that makes like
no difference yeah
then remake as big of a difference for
anime as I I feel for like other film
yeah like live action stuff of live
action it's like it's night and day yeah
yeah
um and I've tested it and I've like
tested uploading 4K rendered videos for
a 1080p video uh which should just make
no difference because all you're doing
is upscaling the pixels and it looks
better because
if you upload in 4k YouTube just go
YouTubers yeah you know because then
people who can watch it in 4k be able to
watch it and basically a less compressed
version of 1080p yeah uh also for like
if you're ever doing anything with like
actual cameras the reason why you want
higher high resolution which is super
useful is you can punch in and it
doesn't look like [__] yeah digital you
can zoom you can like yeah zoom in the
frame a lot yeah
um that's very useful like sometimes if
you ever like you know people's like oh
8K camera why the [__] would you ever
need that it's like the one benefit is
that like let's say if uh me and Joey
are in the same frame we're next to each
other and it's 8K you could zoom in on
me and it would still look like 2K yeah
you know what I mean and it wouldn't
look like Blurry as [__] yeah
um sorry this is like whole technical
stuff but it's like it's not interesting
but it's just like and I'm sure there's
some camera experts who can who are like
no it's not how it works but it's like
get them okay that's how it feels as a
tech nerd do you think we'll need more
than 4K eventually do you think we'll
get up to like you know 16k 32k TVs and
stuff like that well I don't I don't
think it'll I mean they'll certainly be
available because but I don't know
because I remember back in the day
people said that about 1080p that's what
I'm saying yeah like back in the day
like early YouTube when like the most
you could go was like 7 20 or even like
480. we were like oh 720 is is wow
that's HD that's that looks good and now
we're like oh I don't know I certainly
think the cameras uh will definitely
keep getting higher resolution just
because it's more useful again for
editing yeah and being able to
manipulate them yeah I'm not talking
about like the editing thing I'm talking
about me losing my eyes I mean they'll
probably get there but it probably will
be like such such diminishing returns
yeah especially 4K to 8K is like I'm I'm
dude it's barely anything because like
okay for me like I see people freaking
out over like you know 4K 4K does look
[__] good like straight up it does
look really good like to me okay with
like like my opinion right like I'd be
I'd be blind to say that it doesn't look
better 4K does like object effectively
look better yes
um but like in terms of like how much it
makes a difference to like whatever like
my immersion or something like that it's
just it's it doesn't like the the amount
the amount of like new pixels and the
amount of resolution you're adding just
doesn't feel as different to when 1080p
was just introduced versus like 360
people yeah and it just feels like the
the returns are getting more diminishing
the like well yeah right now it's way
more about you know how was it filmed
and how is it uh how are the colors yeah
I was about to say like you know it's
it's way more about lighting and colors
now that's why there's a giant focus on
HDR oh no yeah I totally agree where I
think like from from my own personal
like perspective if something is lit and
filmed correctly in 1080P
way more important than just having like
a 4K resolution yeah
um obviously if you can combine both
then [__] [__] incredible yeah but
I feel like this
focus on just having something that's
like higher resolution 4K it was like to
me it doesn't make that much of a
difference yeah and uh it's crazy how
much lighting is everything yeah right
it's really like insane yeah like
because you know when you're starting on
YouTube you're like I'm gonna get a
little Sony little camera just a little
and then you're like why does it look
like ass yeah like why does every other
YouTubers videos look so good and mine
looks so dogs oh it's because I'm using
a tiny [__] desk lamp it's because I
have no light I'm also the sun is behind
me and uh I have a flickering light in
the back you're just like oh yeah yeah
oh this [__] sucks you're like I have
to make the whole room well balanced and
I have to make sure I'm lit and then the
background's lit differently otherwise
it just looks like found footage yeah
because like my you know like my stream
setup is like I have two lights for my
face yeah and then the the rest of the
room is lit differently and it's like it
looks it's insane how different it looks
like if I turn the lights off I never
showed you with the lights on you'd
think oh it's not that bad I turn them
on you're like oh whoa It's like a lot
different oh yeah for sure it's it's
yeah it's it's uh it's annoying because
you're like as a YouTuber you want to
always improve your videos and you want
to well I suppose if you're a good video
I guess a good YouTubers
listen if you if you're a professional
anything or you'd claim to be you should
be always looking how to get better at
it right of course you know like [__]
uh Van Gogh didn't paint one picture
he's like I'm done boys that's it no
more I'm gonna that's it I've made it
you know like you always want to improve
right yes if you're passionate about it
absolutely and the thing that sucks
about being a YouTuber is that like
you're like okay I want to upgrade my
audio and you're like holy [__] this is
complicated how the F to get like 10
better audio I have to learn like a
hundred percent more worth of like
information yeah I'm saying like 10
times the price as well yeah and pay
like quadruple the price yeah especially
with camera gear oh my God cameras and
lighting it it's it's insane how
exponentially it goes up for like again
diminishing returns yeah yeah like you
can look like Marcus Brownlee but do you
have the money of Marcus Bradley and
more importantly do you have somebody
who knows how to then use that stuff yes
you can buy these like Cinema RED
cameras but if you if you don't got a
good lighting guy and a good and a good
uh like person who knows how to do all
the coloring in the software yeah you're
[__] yeah for sure which I don't
yeah which is why it's it's weird seeing
if like just like my philosophy which is
isn't always about making things let's
say look the most highest resolution and
stuff like that I'm more I'm like way
more focused on like writing and like
just editing I mean I think because
you're so focused on anime yeah and you
don't show your face in all your videos
like it doesn't matter like it's kind of
like it's kind of like the uh you know
Nintendo and Microsoft versus like the
uh sorry the Nintendo versus the
Microsoft and Sony group you know
[__] you got like the PS5 and the
Xbox series X or whatever that's just
like power more power
more pixels are the Nintendo's like I'm
gonna do weirdo [__] let's uh it's like
when you have those like in my mind I
see it as like let's say you have a
YouTube Vlog yeah uh and it's from like
a smaller Channel and they've just
started it's like it's goddamn like the
camera work everything is just [__]
awful and no one has a certain charm
towards that there is a bit of a charm
but also if you just straight up can't
see what they're trying to film you're
like great
you just wasted like this entire point
like I can't say anything and it's all
I'm gonna be opening up Pokemon cards
today in a dark room yeah oh here's my
hat yeah
I don't know
there's a charm I don't I don't think I
don't think Sean doesn't get you to like
yeah I don't think a content creator can
always remain that kind of level but
like I would something about having
seeing like a new YouTuber or something
and them having like the shittiest
[__] mic that piece every five
seconds
something about that I'm just like you
know what maybe this is Peak YouTube I
don't know anymore you know this is yeah
I think I think an important part of
being a YouTuber especially one that
does well is that you you make you
upload your video and you're like that's
good and then you watch another person's
video like oh
way better than what I just uploaded
yeah and then you're like how did they
do that and you start just figuring it
out yeah for sure yeah speaking of like
you know higher resolution better
technology and stuff like that I did
also see Avatar 2 as well
right yeah but you really didn't really
go fall into it yeah yeah yeah I didn't
really get fully into it and what's your
rating I kind of got a lot of [__] for
his take on Avatar I did people would
people were clowning on me for calling
it kind of bit like boring yeah I said
the visuals look good but the story was
boring and I'm like Connor I agree yeah
I agree
I got it I gotta defend myself
I gotta defend my boy during his Avatar
anyone who pretends that story is like
amazing I just don't I I they have to be
capping like they I don't trust anything
they say because because like I remember
Conor saying that he fell asleep during
like the middle portion of Avatar and
didn't miss anything and I'm just like
huh kind of monkey moment and I remember
sitting there three hours in and I'm
like [__] I wish I fell asleep the
middle is straight up like nothing like
you don't need to be awake for it right
like at all yeah because I'm like
because
I remember during the middle portion
which was I think the portion that
really like that that was a portion that
was like the hardest to get through for
me
um
let's remake Avatar one but with a new
like new Navi before I start [__] on
Avatar I don't think it's a bad film no
but it's not like the absolute
Masterpiece whatever I don't think it's
a bad film I just I just walked out of
it being like [__] man three that was
three hours of my life holy [__] that
was a long three hours of my life
because uh the middle portion was a very
very
nice Tech demo is what I felt it's this
it had some of like the most
breathtaking shots I've seen in film
especially in the cinema
um but I'm just like this is this is uh
this is a [__] Sony Bravia Tech demo
that I'm seeing just to show how good
the TV is right now yeah I mean I I
stand by what I said I just think it's
it's it's a good it's a solid movie The
visuals carry a lot of that and the
stories just kind of met yeah because
like I don't really care much for the
characters because I was thinking
there's there's I really really really
want to like Avatar uh yeah me too yeah
because like if like I was I was looking
at it and I'm just like this is this is
almost an isaka you know this is this is
almost an isakai this should be my film
you know Jerry tell me I'm wrong tell me
I'm wrong Joey it just doesn't have the
reincarnation bit but he [__] wakes
up in another world he's he's a totally
different being he doesn't have the
reincarnation but therefore it is
nothing like it is
like the characters did you like that it
was all blue people did you
um you're a fan of blue people I I
[__] hate blue okay
his his mind he was like my biggest
problem with Avatar too it wasn't
this it wasn't so much the story it was
the fact that it was three hours long
okay uh because I think round about 30
minutes in I was like I think I know
every major story beat that's going to
happen in this story yeah and I was
completely right everything I thought
was going to happen just happened so
what I'll so in my mind I was just like
okay I know we need to set up the bad
guy we need to like do this and it's
like a fish out of water but I'm just
here for like I I I knew all of all I
knew all of this was going to happen so
in my mind I was just rush I was like
kind of like subconsciously wanting it
to rush itself to be like right okay I
know what's gonna happen can we just get
to the payoff that I know you are
setting up because I I know I know
what you need to do to like set up the
bad guy and set up the action scenes or
something like that I'm just like can we
just get to the action scenes faster and
I don't I don't feel like the story kind
of was good enough to be three hours
long to keep me engaged the entire time
to get to the payoff which was like
[__] two two hours in and by that
point I was already mentally very
fatigued so I was I I think fatigue is
the right word because I felt fatigued
watching the middle portion of Avatar
too do you know what I felt like it felt
like a TV series more than it did a film
in some sense yeah I'd say so yeah
because if if this was a TV series I
think I would have enjoyed it more
because it if it was like three hour
long episodes versus just marathoning
three episodes of watch I could I could
have like taken a break in something
like that you basically watched about
six to seven episodes of anime back to
back yeah all right
you almost binge the series basically I
watched the season long
I watched a season-long anime you could
watch all of Golden Boy in that time
isn't that crazy
yeah because I feel like you know I
could see what he was trying to do with
kind of setting up this family drama and
stuff like that and I really really want
to be invested in this world because one
thing I will say is that it truly got me
immersed in this world of Avatar one
thing that I think Avatar's biggest
strength is every time I watched an
iteration of the film you totally get
immersed in this world that James
Cameron has like set up and I think it's
like truly amazing
um that he can get you to like kind of
like yeah immerse you this deeply
because I I don't think I can think of
another film that immerses me this
deeply into another world
um I just wish the story was a bit more
exciting do you feel that way about Dune
did you feel like I felt that way about
Dune as well right yeah and do not doon
dinner was pretty long as well wasn't it
was just over two just over two it's
about two hours it was about two hours I
don't know it's like Dune didn't feel as
long even though I don't think he had as
many like action set pieces yeah like
not that not that much happened in the
Dune movie yeah I'm just setting up the
world but it's [__] epic I mean it
was only the first third of the first
book right yeah yeah because I think I
think the difference between Dune and
Avatar is that they both have like very
very interesting worlds Avatar just
focus Avatar just chooses to focus on
none of the stuff I think is interesting
you know what I mean yeah like Avatar's
like said like I think the entire like
background premise of advertised really
[__] interesting like you have um
you have this world where Earth is dying
um and I'm gonna slightly spoil Avatar
too uh but uh the main villain from
Avatar one comes back okay uh because
what happens is that yeah
I see I I didn't like the fact that this
was such an interesting concept that
they just did not [__] utilize at all
so what happens is the main villain from
Avatar one comes back and that's because
just before his final like suicide
mission he stored his memories and sent
his Memories Back To Earth
to be was this like the Matrix yeah yeah
kind of yeah
yeah so his memories is implanted in
this new Avatar right okay I don't think
this is a spoiler because this is
literally in the trailer
um and I that to me that's a [__]
interesting car that's cool the kind of
morality of being like Oh I'm a new
human being who's kind of the clone of
this original one but not really yeah
and I'm like there are so many
interesting [__] Avenues you could
take with just his like just being a
person that is kind of a clone that has
woken up in a [__] alien they could
have gone down like the Ghost in the
Shell right yeah yeah and then he was
just like yeah I'm not I'm not the same
person but I am okay moving on bad
person okay I'm gonna shoot all the blue
people now and I'm like [__] [__] yeah
yeah he doesn't question he doesn't
question anything and I'm like yo if I
woke up as like I guess that's like
maybe his personality that would be the
argument he's so jaded that it doesn't
even crosses he's so militarily focused
I don't know yeah
[Laughter]
I did not like the kids at all I I feel
like it's so hard to make kids likeable
in movies yeah because you know the kids
that they're little shits yeah my God I
had no interest in Jake Sully's children
I did not care no no I I agree I think
one one of the thing that really I
really noticed was that it was three
hours long
um two hours about [__] kids yeah two
hours about [__] kids well not
[__] kids but yeah bro rephrase that
please two two hours about the kids and
somehow in the two hours I think because
the cast was so big it just didn't
didn't give me enough time it didn't
give me enough time to care about the
kids I don't know
I don't know with their personalities
there's no amount of time would make me
like that all right I just I just don't
care yeah I just I just didn't care
that's that's my vote yeah I just it's
such an interesting amazing sci-fi world
that James Cameron has set up and it
just God I wish James Cameron made
something else
I was I wish so too I think James
Cameron has like a hard on for water I
don't know something apparently this
movie has to break 2 billion to break
even yeah which it's looking like like
since since last time
um it's doing pretty well well it's like
it's like 1.7 bill right now I think
yeah isn't that insane though just to
get 2 billion to break even yeah what
insane number God damn man yeah but have
you seen like I James Cameron is like an
incredible filmmaker and I really like
if anyone has seen the behind the scenes
of oh no yeah it's insane yeah it's the
it's [__] insane like you know the
amount of times you've just he's just
like wanted to do something that doesn't
exist so he's like I'm just gonna invent
the technology to do it yeah just
because I want to do it in my film other
than this technology just ends up
revolutionizing the entire [__] film
industry
again there's just no slight on him as a
director he's clearly an extremely
talented guy and a junior films and
Technology but man I just don't care
about Avatar
both these films I guess I'll just see
what happens see the question is it
worth uh after hearing your guys's
opinions on it do you think I should
still go and watch it yeah okay
yes it depends on Avatar three and four
because I remember you gotta have an
opinion on it yeah I kind of want to
have it yeah I also don't want to waste
three hours of my life because I I felt
like I'm going to okay so I just watched
like a cliff notes version of it just
should I just watch clips on YouTube go
into the movie an hour and a half in
I'll just be late
I'll spend an hour and a half buying
popcorn getting dinner somewhere and
then I'll just be like oh yeah because
God God damn like some of the some of
the imagery in in the middle which uh in
the middle was [__] beautiful but
after about two seasons I was like okay
I understand now it's pretty can we get
to uh can we get back to the story right
um and yeah I said last time that I
don't think the visuals would have you
know it is the best looking film I've
ever seen but I don't I didn't think the
visuals could blow my mind as much as
seeing the Avatar one did and yeah
that's how I felt it was it was good but
okay nothing mind-blooded didn't blow my
mind like the first time I saw Avatar
one but that's just because film
technology just looks so good now yeah
it's so hard okay um James Cameron if
you're watching this which you're
probably not you've made an incredible
world and you it's a world with so much
potential for really interesting ideas
that you can take the story
um
this is my personal opinion if you could
take Avatar three and four in some other
direction other than invading people bad
blue people good then I would I would I
would love that because I really want to
get invest into Avatar I don't think he
has the potential yeah for sure
can you write it can you write an
Instagram yeah uh The Last of Us show is
pretty good oh did you watch that yeah
it really is yeah I haven't played the
games but the show's [__] good okay
it's very good you should watch it I
mean the game's okay here's here's the
thing about The Last of Us tell me the
thing about the last time they would
have to [__] up really hard to make The
Last of Us show bad because I feel like
The Last of Us game is already a HBO
show with gameplay it's true but I I
think that there is still that you do
still have to kind of translate certain
things to a screen that are a bit hard
to do oh for sure yeah and I think also
obviously you know you've got to get
these you've got to make people fall in
love with these main characters again
yeah
um and all you need to do is just take
the writing from the game it's well yeah
there are some some sentences that are
straight from the game yeah um but yeah
I mean Pedro Pascal is like amazing okay
yeah it's so [__] good yeah
everything I've seen him in he's just
been the girl and also he's like he's a
really good meme the one where he's
crying and laughing oh yeah there's
someone from that's from a like a zoom
acting class that he's doing and the
director's like Okay show them somebody
who's uh happy but then so like it was
like some kind of motivation where
something good uh bad happens and they
don't know how to deal with it right it
just literally just goes
it's really the full Club is even
weirder all right it's pretty fun though
but it's so good please watch it it's
you want it's something like one episode
out right now one episode out of the
time of recording dating your episode uh
but yeah no even the one episode was it
was so funny I I I would bet a lot of
money that it's gonna keep being great
because I they would really have to do
something dumb to [__] this up yeah so
far it's a pretty simple story I haven't
yeah I haven't uh simple uh Simple Story
complex characters you know
um and it's usually the best yeah yeah
yeah and I think
it could be Avatar but
um it's just so nice but HBO does
something they're so [__] good at
making TV shows yeah yeah except for
Velma that was bad we don't talk about
that though
action I watched one episode I'm out
yeah I just watched a bunch of Clips on
Twitter and uh oh my God okay horrible
here's the question do you think they
made that show as yes rage bait show yes
oh 100 they could have made a good show
they didn't want to it's HBO they can
make a [__] good show if they want to
make it they're like if you want a TV
series done the best HBO had like the
dudes I don't know who they have on
speed dial but they just don't miss
everything HBO if you look at some of
the best TV shows in history half of
them HBO I feel I feel like just because
they must have some kind of like they
have must have some kind of like big
vetting process about what shows yeah I
think they also have like a roster of
like just really great writers directors
everything like they just they've been
doing it so long and I think they just
they're just great I don't know I again
I just shouldn't be speculating but I
mean the history has been around for a
very long time and they've they clearly
have you know some of the most impactful
shows on like pop culture they've had
um so Thelma is not going to be one of
those it's had an impact it has had an
impact because
right like uh House of dragon
um what else is HBO Band of Brothers
this is HBO yeah because I've always
felt like they've had a very their
approach to TV shows has always been
very cultivated you know it's it's
something that they don't approve every
show I'm like like Netflix yeah every
show that they do approve is always of
like the highest quality yeah I kind of
feel similar to like going to like the
manga world like Shonen Jump I don't
know I don't know what the Shonen Jump
secret sources you know but somehow
every generation they are able to make
the biggest and most impactful anime
shows I mean I mean their generation
yeah I'm sure with Townsend authors but
I'm also I you know there's probably the
dudes who are curating turn and jump
yeah you know if I'm a new uh mangako or
anything right and you've got these
dudes who've been working at 40 years
who can give you any insight and can
steer you in the right direction like
that's that's probably worth a lot I
mean they say it's harder to get a
serialization or Shonen Jump than it is
to be accepted into Tokyo University I
believe it or just like insane if you if
you ask a Japanese person that all right
like it's literally one in a million
like yeah I can't imagine the amount of
like you know mediocre to [__] manga
that they have to sift through to be
like yeah all right uh we don't know how
to tell you this but uh
go home yeah because it's like it's like
way easier to fall off than to keep
putting out [__] bangers all the time
that's why odor the goat plays the goat
like I remember when uh Naruto and
bleach ended there was this like huge
[__] hole and everyone's like oh the
big three died his anime is Shonen going
to be as popular as it can be and for
like for like a few like for like a good
like three four years nothing came to
like take that spot and I remember
thinking oh maybe maybe this is time for
like other types of shows because that's
when Attack on Titan and one punch man
got really popular yeah and I'm like
okay maybe maybe Shonen Jump is slowly
like falling off who knows maybe they
can't make something as impactful as
Naruto and bleach and then turns out I
they just needed like a [__] buffer
uh because then my hero Academia came
out Demon Slayer chainsaw man Jiu Jitsu
kaisen spy family [__] it just like now
they've gone from like the big three to
like the big seven or eight or some [__]
like that it's got a strong roster yeah
everything's good yeah I'm like what is
the secret so tell me the secrets God
heroin black tongue heroin God please
bring it to the [__] Easter guys we
[__] need that although there is
still that like you know very real scare
that I think all like Shonen fans are
wondering especially jump of like all
right you know a lot of these like good
shows that you you mentioned right like
the you know the carrying but everyone
knows they're behind the scenes one
piece is still carrying Shonen Jump
pretty [__] hard like oda's shoulders
must be cracked because of just how much
he's carrying Shonen jump right now so
everyone I think in the back of their
minds is like all right what's gonna
happen
like what's gonna happen to Sean and
John win one piece I know we don't need
to worry about that we don't need to
worry yeah so they're just like I bet
like shoe Asia just like begging odor to
be like please don't stop I beg of you
oh they'll make Luffy the emperor
I'm scared because I don't think one
piece is going to die I think it's going
to be a boruto kind of situation I mean
are we gonna get a two-piece yeah
because you started reading one piece
you're not like completely up to date
but you can already tell that the world
of one piece is so [__] vast that I
already know they're gonna try to
they're gonna try to spin-offs not like
I wouldn't say milk it but it has
potential for so many interesting
stories within the world like a ton of
prequels already from what I've seen
that I'd be like I'd like to know what
happened before I mean they're already
doing that like they released like a an
ace story prequel in the long end that's
like popped off recently yeah so it's
like yeah they're already doing it but
like the moment one piece actually ends
they're like all right we're gonna list
out all these characters that didn't get
enough backstory just make individual
Manga and Anime though Otis seems like
the kind of dude who's not gonna stop
writing manga until he physically cannot
like yeah you see it like just saying
one piece you're like this dude's not
gonna stop no like this is not the type
of dude who says I think I'm done
he is the type of dude who will be like
I am just gonna not stop doing this
until I physically am unable to oh yeah
yeah for sure yeah I just I just hope
okay here's here's my hope because I
know Ori discovers like a type of porn
he likes or something or he discovers
Idol muscles
you know there's the two there's there's
a couple of ways you can have downfalls
yeah oh no let me introduce you to the
world of genjun impact oh my God could
you imagine it's like ah this week uh
one piece is on Hiatus because Oda
discovered
no because like the one thing I wish for
when one piece ends is that they give us
some time a few years to mourn because I
feel like you know do you know what I
mean yeah because like you know when
when something's not Clarity right when
something ends sometimes you just need a
little time to just let that ending sink
in and just know okay that that's it uh
because I felt like with Naruto I
remember reading that last chapter and I
was just like [__] man a part of my
childhood has died
um and then narrative the last movie got
announced like immediately afterwards I
was like
Jesus Christ Matt come on give me some
time here man come on I'm just it's like
it's like a family member dying and then
you're not being like here's your brand
new cousin it's like come on man I just
attended your funeral man come on I'm
mourning you right now come on Daddy
chill please come on oh my God like like
I I know they're not I'm not gonna let
one piece die straight away but I hope
at least they'll let the Legacy
sink in for a little bit before they
start [__] milking the [__] out yeah
yeah I hope so that's that's that's my
hope at least yeah who knows but hey
look at all these patrons though are you
excited or sad or Mourning the potential
loss of One Piece soon
everyone yeah and by soon I mean the
next 10 years relative soon it's a
relative relative soon yes but uh Hey if
you like to support the show then go to
our patreon patreon.com trashtaste also
follow us on Twitter send us your memes
on the subredit and if you had our face
listen to us on Spotify and uh yeah I
guess we'll end it at that yeah yeah see
you guys next week bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign